bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors selon vous
est-ce que l'espace schengen est en
danger c'est toute l'union européenne
qui est en danger puisque l'union
européenne est fondée sur à la fois on
pas diluer néo classique qui consiste à
lutter contre les déficits publics qui
ont explosé à mutualiser une monnaie
alors qu'il n'y a pas d'état et le
budget commun et on voit les problèmes
que ça soulève et enfin a considéré qu'
il faut supprimer les frontières
or l'urgence sanitaire a cédé rétablie
elle le fait elle même la tempête ont
prouvé les justifier est justifiée par
une politique qui est elle-même balayé
la portée de cette question du retour de
l'europe sans passeport sera abordée
lors du prochain sommet européen des 27
ce sera le 23 avril qu'est ce qu'on peut
en attendre
en fait je crois qu'il ya l'idée d'un
avantage tout à fait marginale qui est
que l'on peut circuler plus facilement
son schengen quand on parle en vacances
même pour les hommes d'affaires mais ça
c'était un avantage 10 sont extrêmement
limités comme d'ailleurs d'autres
avantages comme peut représenter les
fonds erasmus qui fonctionne très bien
tout ça ce sont des avantages je dirais
tout à fait amex
en fait lui le ça se paye si vous voulez
7 ces avantages annexes anecdotique se
taillent finalement par un mécanisme qui
attachent les nations européennes les
unes aux autres et qui les empêchent
d'agir qui les empêche de se projeter
finalement sur sur leur destin donc
d'avoir un destin elle même et c'est si
vous voulez donc vous parler de rétablir
la circulation à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen avec des passeports mais moi je
vous réponds qu au delà de ça cette
espèce de l'it procuste monétaire et et
c'est cet accélérateur de la
mondialisation qui a constitué l'union
européenne de toute façon il va falloir
en parler alors c'était pas gagné en
mêlée les 27 ministres des finances de
l'ue se sont accordés sur un plan de
relance de 500
hier d'euros comment est ce que vous
voyez ce consensus alors on sait que
c'est un peu compliqué du côté des
pays-bas et de l'allemagne
est ce que vous le jugez comme étant un
fait marquant dans le contexte actuel
n'ont non seulement pas c'est pas du
tout un plan de relance c'est à nouveau
ce à quoi on a l'habitude en novembre
c'est à dire que c'est pas l'art pour
l'art c'est l'europe pour l'europe il
faut sauver l'europe pour sauver
l'europe sauver le soldat bruxelles mais
en fait derrière de quoi s'agit-il il
s'agit d'un fonds qui avait été mise en
place après la crise des dettes
souveraines qui s'appelle le maine usa
le mécanisme européen de stabilité qui
consiste qui considère que les avances
qui sont faites qui sont consentis aux
états devront être remboursés c'est bien
évidemment une folie cette ce montant
gigantesque de dette publique qui a été
qui était déjà très important a
quasiment impossible à rembourser pour
certains états dont la france a été
considérablement aggravée par la crise
du coc vide
donc c'est une non remboursable on
courait sens dans une une sorte de
fantaisie ça leur fait plaisir de croire
qu'on va rembourser c'est possible mais
mathématiquement c'est impensable et
impossible économiquement ce serait
tragique aussi d'essayer de rembourser à
tout prix ses avances
il faut les considérer comme des dons
union européenne n'en n'est absolument
pas là mais le plus et de plus
extraordinaire de tout ça c'est qu'ils
arrivent à se faire croire à eux mêmes
alors à nous faire croire je ne pense
pas mais à se faire croire en eux mêmes
en tout cas qu'on est dans un plan
marshall 500 milliards de dollars contre
l'union européenne c'est absolument
dérisoires les états unis ont mobilisé
deux mille milliards l'allemagne la
mobilité pour son seul territoire 1000
milliards ça donne une idée du caractère
de ce volontarisme saut de puce ce
caractère dérisoire de ce que fait
l'union européenne mais en plus ils nous
mentent parce que c'est pas du tout une
injection d'argent frais ça c'est la bce
qui le fait par ailleurs real a pas le
choix c'est pas une injection d'argent
frais du tout c'est pas une
mutualisation du tout c'est simplement
un mécanisme qui est un mécanisme qui
avait été prévu pour la crise des dettes
souveraines et qui permet d'avancer de
l'argent mais d'avancer des sommes qui
sont très limitées finalement dans nos
salons vous qu'est ce qui se joue en ce
moment pour un l'union européenne sa
survie je pense que l'union européenne
est nette au stade des soins palliatifs
elle est avec un respirateur
quelque sorte l'union européenne s'est
aussi on s'en rend compte ça a été un
formidable accélérateur de la
tiers-mondisation de la paupérisation
d'une partie des états membres avec un
mécanisme dont on n'a pas le temps de
détailler la mais qui est très simple à
comprendre c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où vous installez une monnaie
avec des économies qui ont des
productivités différentes que par
ailleurs on n'avait pas de budget ou de
l'affectio societatis pour reprendre
l'expression des romans c'est à dire un
budget c'est une si le fait qu'on est
d'accord sur l'emploi du budget qu'on
est d'accord sur la mutualisation les
dépenses c'est à dire qu'en fait la
paribas peut aider marseille paris peut
aider les dom-tom là y'a rien de tel à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne parce
qu'il ya pas de pop il épate affectio
societatis donc ce jeu je pense que
l'union européenne se révèle être disons
non seulement quelque chose qui a rendu
la crise beaucoup plus violente chez
nous par l'effet du libéralisme c'est le
même libéralisme et qui fait des ravages
aux états unis on le voit qu'il soutient
mal le choc de la pandémie
mais l'union européenne c'est une idée
c'est une idée du passé c'est l'union
soviétique si vous voulez c'est quelque
chose qui est complètement dépassé par
l'histoire il faudrait d'une
fragmentation des confinés sur une base
est l'expression la nation de s'était
pas d'hystérie qu'est l'union européenne
merci pour votre regard guillaume bigot
politologue et essayiste